there's how many coins out there in
total best guess i don't know like 16
000 now i was gonna say there's like 10
15 20 20 000 between 10 and 20 000 how
many of these 10 to 20 000 coins that
are out there will be here long term 5
10 twenty years from now what do you
think leia i mean like three
three
bitcoin so 99 yeah wipe them out no i
didn't disagree hold on so what do you
what do you think will be here yeah so i
mean firstly we have to understand that
like regulation is coming and
particularly to the states right and i
think the majority of the tokens that we
have right now are securities solana is
a security it's entirely vc backed and
so those securities are going to be
totally wiped out and then you have
bitcoin which obviously isn't a security
and is something completely different
and completely separate ethereum i also
think we'll be here just given the
internet is being built on it sorry
jessica um but other than that i think
about three maximum so you have
longevity of bitcoin you have ethereum
and you have what else
i'm okay those are my two that i'm only
that i would only really stand by i'd
accumulate other stuff i've got ada
which is cardano i'm interested to see
what that will do although i'm not super
bullish on it got it and you said no no
no you believe more than three it's the
same way with companies bro like you
have like ten percent or no actually
like three percent of the coins that
will exist and that's fine because for
example ap coin from board ape uh you
know it's a proven
uh go-to-market strategy that worked
they created the community they launched
nfts
massive hype and the coin is fine you
know what i'm saying like it won't go
anywhere because bar they've created
such a notable ip and such a strong
community that the the coin will you
know remain here so i just don't think i
think on the notion of bitcoin ethereum
you know
the financial oriented type of
cryptocurrencies yes but then for on the
realm of community driven you know coins
or metaverse coins or nft coins there's
plenty of space for points just to give
a clear number you said three percent to
maybe ten percent yeah like you're
saying no no no yeah i know it's like
companies it's like you know
so she said basically one percent you're
saying three she said coins three okay
so she's like point one percent yeah
apologies jessica do you have any strong
feelings on what will be here long term
oh um bitcoin in ethereum like she said
there's so much being being built
especially um i don't know something
like uh half of it is stored in like
amazon cloud type thing i can't remember
because i don't own any of it so uh i'm
not an expert i don't own anything other
than bitcoin no i i own some shares of
twitter but not enough to
[Music]